Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO! BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for our 64th episode!
Like an N64?
Today's the FWMC64?
Is that what you're thinking about or hi?
That's what I'm thinking about!
BAU BAU!
FWMC64.
Well, unfortunately we don't have any game news because this is FUWAMOCO Morning!
And in case you're joining us for the very first time today,
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
On the right paw.
And what gets us on the right paw other than a Pero Sighting?
Okay.
Okay, Ruffians.
Well, what do you have for today?
Let's see.
De-den!
Uh...
Well, like, you know, it's, I guess it's the beginning of a new year and with the new year, you know, it's good to take a look at the scenery and nothing beats looking out and gazing at the majestic Mount Fuji.
Except for, you know, when a very big peril blocks your view.
What happened to him?
Hi.
Yeah, uh, maybe he had a very happy Christmas or New Year's.
Oh, so like, maybe he ate a bunch of family's osechi?
Oh, I thought you were gonna say maybe he ate a whole bunch of family's.
Or, what if he ate a whole bunch of family's?
Maybe he just had too much mochi, so that, you know, he became the mochi himself.
Actually, I wouldn't mind becoming mochi, too.
You know!
But we already know!
It doesn't quite work, huh?
Fuwa-mochi!
Moco-mochi!
Actually that works pretty well, no?
I'm Fuwawa, your mochimochi.
Moco-mochi.
I wonder what would happen if we gave Pero a little bit of a push.
I wonder what kind of scream he'd make, you know.
Right, Ruffians?
Could be kind of a delicious scream.
Mochi delicious!
BAU BAU!
Something that's even a better sign than last year!
Ruffians!
We told you last FUWAMOCO Morning to not forget about our new year outfit reveals, right?
And, well, that's because...
They're happening today!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
You didn't forget, right?
Today is Advent's first new outfit!
We're very excited.
In case you didn't know, we know.
But today!
We finally get to share them with you today!
Today!
Yeah!
We'll be doing a really starting at 5pm PT over on Shiori's channel.
Shiori's the first to share with you.
And then we're gonna be ending off everything with a collab that you won't want to miss right here on our channel.
I'm not certain but I have a feeling.
There might be some surprises to us!
Right!
So you know!
You wanna be there!
Yeah!
And you know, Ruffians, it means a lot to us too, because as silly as it sounds, we really never thought we'd get special outfits like these, so we want you to be there to celebrate it with us and all of Advent!
Okay!
We know it's a bit exciting, but we hope you won't miss it, okay?
Make sure to take deep breaths beforehand, okay?
Deep breaths, okay?
Are you gonna sneeze?
Like that, okay?
Like that.
That was a deep breath.
BAU BAU!
That's a very deep breath, right?
Well, Ruffians!
You know, not just Advent's New Year outfit relay, but there's also some even more exciting things coming up for FUWAMOCO English!
Wow, you might have heard, but Rei-senpai just announced a big project that's featuring all of us!
She's been working on it
It's a song cover of Minecraft!
Back in the summer, you know, Bibi-senpai happened to win 1 million yen the whole summer bingo.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
That just makes things more exciting!
Yeah, and look at the main visual there for this!
It's so beautiful and colorful!
And the alternate outfit designs too!
Ruffians.
What do you think of FUWAMOCO?
Ah, cute.
We're a little bit far apart from each other, right?
That's fine.
We live on both sides, you know?
Yeah, you know.
Sandwiching in two pieces of bread, you have your Fuwawa slice and your Mococo slice.
Right?
Just like bread.
And you know what?
Actually, I don't mind because look at Nerissa.
Why?
She's especially cute there with the outfit and the skirt and all the pantyhose.
Just a little longer maybe?
BAU BAU!
And again, once more, thank you very much!
I'm so excited.
Ruffians, we haven't had some sneak peeks, sneak listens.
Exciting.
BAU BAU!
Fubuki-senpai has something pretty cool going on right now.
She just released
BAU BAU!
You know, to celebrate the ASMR set coming out, the two of them did a super fun 3D stream where they tried out a whole bunch of silly voice lines with an ASMR mic.
It was pretty crazy, huh?
Fubuki-mama!
There's so many ears all over the place too.
Lots of ears.
Yeah, well, before they performed an intense final song together,
Pacho read some of the rave reviews from Fubuki-senpai from her ASMR set that she received.
And you know, there was one reviewer named Fluff and Fuzz-san.
I wonder who that could have been, hoi.
It's confusing, hoi.
Well, it was a really fun stream and we want to say a big congratulations to both Bubuki-senpai and Patrasche too!
Omedetou!
BAU BAU!
And FUWAMOCO, we don't really know that much about ASMR yet, but we hope that maybe this year we can try to learn as much as we can about ASMR too!
Well, also Ruffians, you know it's been almost six months now.
Probably by this time, you kind of realize, you kind of recognize what FUWAMOCO's sleeping habits are.
And I'll be like, the best.
Well,
I know it!
Sometimes, you know, just can't help it.
You know, night or day, we're working on things!
We're going!
But, sometimes...
You know, being up at times when our senpai are streaming is a pretty great time.
You know, because yesterday we were able to fall into Subaru-senpai's special call-in stream.
You know, finally we had our first proper one-on-one conversation with her.
It was a lot of fun!
You know, I got to call her Subaru-senpai.
And with BAU BAU,
Shuba-shuba together too!
Shuba-shuba!
She's so cool and funny and charismatic, too.
I know.
Saikou deshita!
Aikatta ne!
We really hope that we can grow to become a strong, independent group.
Let's hear some days, maybe, collab together sometime soon, too.
Overclocked Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, have you been a little bit busier than normal?
Well, one of the fun things going on was Koyori-senpai's 24 hour stream KONKOYO24!
And, well, we kind of introduced it here, but Advent was invited to play some games with Koyori-senpai too!
Yeah, you know, we were really confident after watching Bijou and Nerissa take it down.
Nerissa.
Nerissa!
Go down!
Now I'm distracted, huh?
Nerissa!
Wait to become FUWAMOCO.
I think it was because I said Bijou and then I was confused.
I'm just a Bijou.
I had to balance it out, you know.
Bijou and Nerissa.
But, you know, after watching them, you know, we were a bit confident.
We thought we'd do well, too.
I know.
We even started out with air hockey.
Yeah, we're pretty confident with air hockey, or at least I was.
What happened, Hai?
And you know, Fuwawa was screaming like she was being... What am I doing?
Maybe it worked well because I...
It was 5am in Japan, so everyone was able to wake up well, huh?
It was a bunch of fun, but unsurprisingly, in the end, we completely lost to Coyote-senpai.
The only thing we did win out was boxing.
But, you know, that was the last game we played, and I feel like she was kinda going
We won!
We won fair and square.
And you know what?
We had lots of fun.
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Mococo Abyssgard!
One of our goals this year is to collab more, so... It's kind of happening.
Happening.
Baby steps.
One little step at a time.
Let's do it today.
Today.
Together.
Today!
BAU BAU!
So many happy things.
Exciting things going on, Ruffians!
It's not hard to have a smile.
But, well, uh... Actually, Ruffians... There's been another misunderstanding.
Or, or, uh... Actually, uh, sorry, no... We haven't had any misunderstanding, alright?
In fact, it seems like for the last few FUWAMOCO Mornings, misunderstandings have been missing.
Huh?
What do you mean missing?
Misunderstandings.
Missing!
Missing.
I know.
Ruffians, they love our misunderstandings, so... Well, you know, maybe it's just that now we've been a part of hololive for a while, you know, people are generally coming to the understanding that, well, that's just FUWAMOCO, you know, nothing weird here, right?
Right?
So you know, what if I say school days is good, right?
That's, that's Fuwawa, right!
You know, what if, what if we call Fubuki, FUBUKI-MAMA!
Right.
Fubuki-senpai would be like, okay.
You know, so what if we do something kinda silly on Twitter, right?
Right, that happens all the time!
That was not me.
Yeah, that's just FUWAMOCO being FUWAMOCO, right?
Right, Ruffians?
Huh?
I don't know if I'm happy about this situation, Ruffians.
Don't think just how!
Nothing's really happening, okay?
I'm sure, you know, there will probably be more misunderstandings in the future, so... Either wait for them, or not, Ruffians.
Make what you were all about, okay?
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU.
Well, you know, New Year 2024.
FUWAMOCO.
It's almost gonna be our half anniversary too.
Girl, you know it!
So maybe we're growing just a bit more fans!
Maybe.
Maybe!
Maybe not.
Let's check out who is the Doggie of the Day today!
We have for the Doggie of the Day!
Our Doggie of the Day today is... Dad!
Mewmaw!
BAU BAU!
That's a lot of fight, Kai.
Right?
So much fight.
Some beautiful locks.
Yeah.
He's a borky boy.
Borky.
Borky boy.
Nine years old.
Masa up so pupu.
Right.
Even though Naima looks rather tiny.
I don't think I want to mess with him, right?
There's a bit of attitude behind all the hair there.
Yeah.
How do we think BAU BAU?
Well, if it's borky, then... BAU!
Sort of like that, maybe Borky. Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Yeah, and even though he might look a little intimidating at first, deep down, he's a sweetie.
Like me.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look.
Ruffians, you've been out on a boat.
Where are you going for walks, huh?
Well, we have de-den!
This is too cool!
BAU BAU!
And next, we have our Question of the Day.
For our Question of the Day, we have De-den!
BAU BAU!
Hello, FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
Congrats on another cover.
White love collision.
I love all the songs you released.
Thank you!
Has FUWAMOCO thought about an official song collab with their senpai?
City pop with Marine or Gura?
Rock with Suisei or Towa?
No matter what, I'll loop them!
You bet it!
Is that a threat?
It's not a threat.
That just, you know, that sounds too cool, right?
Well, we'd absolutely love to sing anything with our senpai!
Of course!
And I know that's a big reason why we're so excited about Minecraft too, because what can't we do?
I get to be singing with my senpai for the first time!
And as you might know, Ruffians, one of our goals is to sing some J-pop lullies with Marine-senchou-senpai!
So I definitely want to do that if she wanted to, you know?
Agura-senpai too!
Of course!
You know, and I don't know if we're skilled enough yet to sing with Suisei-senpai or Towa-senpai yet.
But, if we're invited, we absolutely do our best!
We still have a bit of improving to do.
A lot of improving.
You know, before we make some of our song collab dreams come true.
But, we'll work on it, okay?
Yeah, you know, we're still just newbies.
So, we want to grow ourselves first, you know?
But, if someone offers... We'll do our best!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much everyone for all your submissions!
We're always keeping an eye out, so please, please use the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
No hashtag, hashtag.
And submit your Pero Sightings, your walks, your doggy of the days.
And also, I know you're pretty good journalist, Ruffians.
FWMC scoop, don't forget, okay?
It's waiting for you.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, all my Ruffians!
Well, for our next stream, we have, in case you didn't know... You didn't forget, right, Ruffians?
We have!
Wait, wait, Moco-chan.
Ruffians, can you announce what the next stream is for us?
Oh, please, go ahead.
Oh!
I wanna hear what you think it is.
We have our New Year Advent Review!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm proud of you, Ruffians.
It's really okay.
So the first one starts at 5pm PT over on Shiori's channel.
Make sure you do, okay?
5pm PT.
That's 10AM JST.
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Time for our schedule!
Let's take a little look.
Wow!
It's kind of different because things changed.
Today is not Mario Kart 8 Deluxe practice.
That's gonna be tomorrow.
Tomorrow at 6PM PT, our usual stream time, we will be practicing some Mario Kart 8 Deluxe.
And then, after that,
Well, we have the holo cup qualifiers.
And then, the next day, we will be having our cozy, cute HF with the Doggy Pack at our usual time, so we hope that you'll be there, okay?
The waiting rooms are all there, okay?
But we'll make sure to update YouTube and also Twitter with the changes, too, so... Thank you, Ruffians, for understanding!
BAU BAU!
Oh wow, before we know it, we're at the end of the first week of 2024.
Crazy.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
Hawkmoon!
BAU BAU!
Mr. Alert!
Joji!
BAU BAU!
Vivar.
Fabian Diaz.
BAU BAU!
Shojin.
Defamira.
BAU BAU!
Im.
Yukoi.
BAU BAU!
Atlus.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!